what is up ladies and gentlemen Steven
from coffee Zillah here or as you may
know me Senor 100k my testosterone
levels are through the roof we're
approaching Dan pineal levels soon so
pretty excited about that but today I
just wanted to come to you guys with a
simple message about Bitcoin scams you
probably know about this I don't feel
like I'm telling many people something
new here but I have some new information
ok for you so every most people should
know that all these bitcoin giveaways
where they say you soon me point one
Bitcoin Olson you point to Bitcoin used
to me one Bitcoin else in you to sue me
for else and you ate whatever it is a
scam of course nobody's gonna send you
that money and at first honestly I
thought
nobody's gonna fall for this so it's not
even worth talking about
iseman that he was talking was saying
when you send me that says one Bitcoin I
send you back to Bitcoin so I understood
that this was looking really so real
but unfortunately till now I didn't
receive any Bitcoin and I send there 1.8
Bitcoin so we try to check everything
drugs everything ok and and a up
you know
as usual I am wrong and people are
falling for this which makes me want to
cover it because not only are they
falling for it the Bitcoin scams are
alive and well on YouTube it amazes me
just this week guys I wasn't planning to
make a video on this except this week
like literally from Sunday to now which
is Wednesday looking at my imaginary
watch which would not have the date on
it okay
from Sunday to Wednesday so for days
anyone into to Wednesday for days I've
seen three of these scams and how these
scams work if you don't know is that
typically they have some famous person
in the title they're faking a channel
name like Bill Gates Foundation but they
have no affiliation with Bill Gates and
they're saying Bill Gates 5000 bitcoin
giveaway and in it they they have like
Bill Gates talking at a famous speech
that's pre-recorded from somebody else
they just rip it onto their video and
then they have some phony website where
you can give them bitcoin okay so the
scam is really formulaic but this is
important to know what they're doing to
pull this off is not basic at all it's
pretty sophisticated and if you're not
careful you might fall for it and I want
to talk about some of the issues so the
first thing they do that surprised me is
that a lot of times they're not using
just burner accounts they're using
hacked accounts so instead of using an
account that they set up yesterday that
has no traction with the algorithm
they're stealing like somebody's 30,000
subscriber you know Channel and running
a Bitcoin scam on it after deleting all
their videos and that's really messed up
because often times the person's channel
gets deleted because of the fact they're
breaking tos by running these
impersonation Bitcoin scams and then
that person who was hacked with no part
in the Bitcoin scam giveaway if they
don't get their channel returned to them
in a month their channel is permanently
deleted and it will never be recovered
we had that happen with Sparky channel
yet remember him the guy we tried to
help well YouTube permanently deleted
his channel so even though YouTube knows
now that his channel was you know Sparky
channel was hacked they can't do
anything for him they just delete data
after a month so what's really messed up
is that
you know YouTube who's not exactly good
at people getting their channels back on
time after their hack will often delete
these channels because they're running
Bitcoin scams and so the person's
original channel which they had nothing
to do with the scam gets deleted so
that's super messed up the other thing
they do which is pretty sophisticated is
they load up these videos with BOTS to
watch it so like on two of the examples
that I'm thinking of from just this week
which I think I have some footage from
16,000 or 20,000 people who are watching
live now obviously there aren't actually
that many people watching live it's just
a bunch of burner BOTS accounts but the
fact that YouTube's algorithm doesn't
pick that up means that they're
promoting it as if it has 16,000 actual
live viewers which means definitely
people organically are being pushed that
video you can see this with Jack Ma
who's a pretty famous figure probably
gets searched a lot that live stream
showed up first in the search results
when you typed in Jack Ma he was the
first thing to show up this fake phony
Bitcoin scam live stream was the first
thing to show up in the search results
so this is a huge problem and the
sophistication of the scam is part of
what makes that possible you couldn't
have done that with just some account
you set up a day ago and not only are
they doing that but now they have bought
chat like they load up the live stream
with viewers but they also have a
chatroom this impressed me honestly the
live chat is loaded with people that are
like supporting the Bitcoin scam
supposedly they're just a bunch of bots
accounts to build the appearance of
trustworthiness and like that it's a
legit thing which is just mind-blowing
to me that someone would go through this
much effort have such a sophisticated
way to scam people but at the same time
the scam isn't that good like we can all
agree I don't think you're wrong for
thinking that even though maybe one
person falls for it maybe two five ten
20 this is hard to fall for this is a
hard scheme to fall for and what did I
what I wanted to tell you guys is that
what worries me is not this scam I think
most people will see right through this
obviously some of you will probably
think it's Stephen why are you even
covering this this is not like most ear
scams which is hard to spot and I
actually agree with you
the reason that I'm pointing it out
though is number one it's all over right
now and I do think that because it's
ranking so high maybe that authority is
getting it lifted up to the point people
would be skimmed but number two what
happens when this gets more
sophisticated like right now obviously
this scam isn't very well thought-out
it's very easy to see it's a scam but
what happens when somebody hijacks an
account and impersonates someone like
Jack Ma Bill Gates Jack Dorsey all these
people that they are constantly
impersonating and actually tries to use
it for misinformation for you know
stealing personal information so instead
of asking for Bitcoin they ask for email
addresses or you know something that's
they're probably more likely to get that
worries me because this stuff if you're
not savvy is hard to spot let me show
you another example which I saw up just
today and this kind of pushed me over
the edge with this whole thing I was
watching a ColdFusion video which if you
haven't seen it already he's a great
channel to watch but I was watching one
of his videos and in the ad bar like
YouTube's
ad bar on the side I didn't get a
screenshot of this because I'm an idiot
there was an advertisement for a Steve
Wozniak video about him giving away
whoops
5,000 Bitcoin and it was for Fox News so
I clicked on it because I know this is
probably a scam I should have
screenshotted the ad but that was
actually one part that I'm surprised by
its YouTube allows these ads in their
ecosystem but then secondly I'm looking
at a Fox News page that has two million
subscribers and I'm thinking to myself
wait honestly had to you know double
take you know that would take three
times and realized that this is not
actually Fox News it it was a fake
account they had faked subscribers up to
two million subscribers before YouTube
eventually caught it and reduced them
back to their original number of eight
subscribers but for a while for a split
second there if you went to their
channel you would really think if you
didn't really dig more that this was the
real fox news it had their banner
it had a subscriber count' that looks
may be similar to what Fox News might
legitimately have and it has this guy
who you kind of trust maybe you like
think oh this guy's famous he's not
gonna lie to me and it's all a gigantic
scam so these things are getting quite
sophisticated not in terms of like their
psychological part I think they're
missing more compelling psychological
elements but in terms of tech
technologically if you can fake your way
to 2 million subscribers if you can you
know impersonate successfully a
mainstream news channel if you can rank
among the most popular names in the
world we have a serious problem on
YouTube and not only that it's getting
channels deleted and I think this is a
gigantic problem that needs more serious
attention by YouTube now in their
defense both of the live streams that I
saw went down and were deleted within I
don't know like 48 hours which is good
but a lot of the videos that I saw were
not deleted and stayed up for a very
long time so you can still find videos
that are months old that are fake
Bitcoin giveaways impersonating famous
people you can find in Tyre Channel
still up like this Robert Kiyosaki
Channel that's not really him that's
impersonating him has 23 thousand
subscribers and is running these scams
so this is something that really needs
to be you know given a look by YouTube
and also you guys need to be aware that
YouTube's bot detection system is good
but it's not great and things will slip
through the cracks at least temporarily
and so you can't just trust a channel
that says it has 2 million subscribers
if it doesn't have the viewership if
it's videos when you go to the video
history if that looks shady run away
guys all in all though I mean I would
just say in general be super careful
with any non-refundable deposit or you
know way of giving money Western Union
all that 99% of the time if someone asks
you exclusively to give them money that
way it is a scam and you should run
after investigating scams for a while I
now purchase almost everything
exclusively with a credit card because I
know
that worse comes to worst if the scam
master gets scammed I can charge back
and that's kind of the beauty of using a
credit card is there's a lot of fraud
measures in place to help you but for
sure don't use anything like Western
Union or Bitcoin which is basically like
if you send it a while it's pretty much
gone so that's all I wanted to say for
now just a quick video for public
awareness about this I imagine a lot of
you guys are seeing this as well so let
me know what you think and before I get
the COTS and I know I'm gonna get them
this guy deserved it who fell for it you
know etc just remember that aspiration
is the antidote to skepticism one of the
reasons he talks about you know wanting
to get that money is because of
coronavirus I'm not easy financial
situation in my life and you know this
coronavirus now he's in desperate
situations so we've all been there
and it sucks but that's why we got to
look out for each other yeah you know
stay away from these scams and you know
I just appreciate you guys showing up
over and over to help fight against
these ridiculous scammers they come in
all shapes sizes and forms as we've seen
you know over the years together so
that's it for now I have a big
investigation in the works and I hope to
show you the guys that soon but for now
don't forget to smash like and subscribe
thank you
[Music]